Speaker 1: All right, Let's do the Friday
mailbag.
You can email info at David Pakman dot com
kicking off 2023.
It's a very full mailbag.
You also sometimes will see a YouTube comment
here or there or a Facebook message that we
get or whatever the case may be.
It's a mix of commentary and we are going
to start with a message from Bruce delivered
via the Facebook where Bruce says, You are
real punk clown.
You make average American sick lie.
That's that's not American.
That's a Narrogin sick, lying, good liberal
girl, whatever your pronoun is f you.
And then after being told, I'm unable to respond
to comments individually.
Bruce writes back.
Not sure why this P.O.S.
lying liberal clown Dave Pacman garbage popped
up on my Facebook but can guarantee I can't
stand feckless lying liberal cowards like
him.
Relay the message to Dave.
He speaks for maybe 29% of Arizona at most.
Effin punk clown.
That's extremely specific.
I speak for 29% of Arizona.
I didn't claim to speak for any of Arizona,
but apparently this guy says it's conceivable
that I speak for 29% of Arizona.
So this is a very angry person who seems totally
disconnected from the reality in his state,
which is more people voted for Katie Hobbs.
Katie Hobbs defeated Kari Lake.
Katie Hobbs is now, thankfully, the governor
of Arizona.
There aren't two governors.
The governor is not Carrie Lake.
Carrie Lake's not the governor elect.
Carrie Lake is not going to use a lawsuit
to become the governor.
Katie Hobbs won.
This guy doesn't like it.
Reality can be tough.
Kevin wrote in.
And Kevin, this one is interesting.
I bet you're like five, seven, one £35 running
your.
The F-word for a gay person liberal mouth.
Like you're intimidating or something.
It's always the unathletic looking pencil
neck nerds like you who talk s like you're
intimidating y or you are the wrong.
You're like, you're intimidating.
You see the name and face.
Remember it you 57f word for a gay person.
Ha ha.
That is unacceptable.
Kevin, I am five eight.
150, please, sir.
Please do not undersell me by an inch.
This is a guy where?
Where?
Clearly he's lost the importance of inches.
That you can tell.
Yeah.
I mean, obviously, we know the best criticism
of someone's political views is their height.
Speaker 3: Or their weight.
Speaker 1: Very, very nicely done.
All right, let's get into some more serious
stuff, Tom.
Tom wrote in about alternatives to prison
for Trump, about a hypothetical Trump trial.
What happens?
Can you even really send Trump to prison?
And Tom writes, David, I predict that Trump
will have to enter a plea deal to avoid a
jury trial after an indictment is handed down.
He won't be able to testify under oath, of
course, and some of the evidence against him
is certain to bring a conviction.
A lot of the evidence Trump wouldn't want
disclosed in open court.
So here is what I think will happen.
Trump will enter an Alford plea allowing him
to plead guilty without making specific admissions.
In allowing this type of plea, the prosecution
will need certain things first.
They'll need for Trump to return the missing
documents he stole.
Without his this action, there should be no
deal.
Then they should require him to withdraw his
candidacy and as a condition, never seek elected
office again, which would prohibit him from
fundraising again.
Lastly, he'll be required to serve in house
detention for a period of time to be determined.
That period of time will prohibit him from
mass communicating fundraising, and he'll
be similarly enjoined from most social activities.
Like most prisoners, this will set up.
This set up will allow the Secret Service
to continue to protect him while serving his
sentence at Mar a Lago.
It's not going to be the perfect answer, writes
Tom.
But the unusual circumstances preclude perfection.
And while I'd prefer that Trump just go to
trial, be convicted and sent to prison, my
sense is that it's just not likely to happen.
Feel free to use this idea for the purpose
of discussing likely outcome scenarios.
Tom That's I mean, it's a it's a very interesting
suggestion.
I've not checked with lawyers about its viability,
but at the surface level, it seems completely
plausible.
I think it is important as my hair does something
very, very weird.
I think it is important that we take it step
by step.
The first step is simply is there going to
be an indictment?
Increasingly, the expectation is, yes.
Let's get to that first step before we go
further.
All right.
Let's now talk about in cells.
Last early last week, I did a commentary about
Incels and the response was overwhelming.
We heard from Incels.
We heard from anti Incels.
We heard from all sorts of people.
So let's go through a few of the messages
that I received.
Danielle wrote in and said, in regards to
how to help Incels, I would propose a more
European approach to the problem.
Many countries in Europe have legal brothels.
The sex industry does not have nearly the
negative stigma in these countries, as in
the U.S..
I don't suggest forcing anyone to work in
prostitution, but I do suggest allowing people
to make the choice of working in a legalized,
regulated and guarded industry.
Daniel writes I am a former incel.
I have had the opportunity to work in Germany
and have used my per diem on several occasions
for recreation in the Reeperbahn brothels.
I found it was possible to build rapport with
some of these women.
When I came back to the U.S., I continued
to pay for female companionship and was able
to build rapport with many of these women.
Gradually, I was able to move to more normal
ways of meeting, interacting and building
relationships with women.
I've not been with a prostitute in over a
decade, but I'm not embarrassed that I found
it to be therapeutic while I was in need of
help.
Sexual desire is a human, natural, human characteristic.
People who are socially challenged should
not be criminalized for seeking to fill this
void, even though it's a business transaction.
Feeling a bit of intimate contact and not
being made to feel like a Frankenstein monster
is a boost to the self-esteem.
Brothels should be readily available to those
in need, writes Daniel.
Very interesting perspective that many people
who emailed shared.
Here's another message from Scott about Incels,
where he says, David, in your recent segment
regarding Incels, you advocated for increased
mental health funding and support for these
individuals, which I think would definitely
be at the base of a multi-pronged effort that
would be needed to address this issue.
However, my feeling is that encouraging these
people to seek one another out so they may
find help or support is sort of what got us
in here in the first place.
Years ago, before social media and online
forums, you never heard about Incels.
Now that people can access social media have
been able to locate other incels, I feel they
get stuck in echo chambers that help to normalize
and rationalize their feelings and that it's
okay to hate women or men or whoever it is.
They feel rejected by that.
It's okay to have thoughts about committing
violence against perceived enemies.
It reminds.
Me very much of the echo chambers.
Many right wing extremists get caught up in
that, normalize and encourage violence.
All this to say I feel like the approach with
Incels should be a little more like deprogramming
people lured into cults and discouraging use
of social media to help with this problem.
I mean, what better way for people to become
sexually active than to get off their devices
and actually interact in the flesh with others
in the real world?
So here's an idea that says not more online
stuff that doesn't seem good.
Nick wrote in and also is thinking legal prostitution
would help.
Saying, David, I watched your segment.
I believe federally legalizing prostitution
would really help this issue.
The reality is that not everyone is going
to be able to find a partner.
Giving those people the option to pay for
sex would really benefit their mental health
by giving them an outlet for their sexual
frustration.
It's basically just providing a service to
solve a problem, just like anything else.
If not for stigma surrounding prostitution
in America, I believe Incels would almost
cease to exist.
What are your thoughts?
Some certainly would.
I think for many of them, the anxiety of even
going to a sex worker would prevent them from
doing it.
I don't know.
I think there's something to this idea, but
I think we need to explore it probably a little
more more deeply.
Rich wrote in and says, Thank you from an
INCEL.
David Sir, I commend and thank you for your
segment on incels.
I am an incel.
I joined an emotional support group on Facebook.
After some time I express my loneliness and
frustration and desire to improve my experience
with dating.
I got absolutely torn apart by people accusing
me of all kinds of nasty things.
Not one person commiserated or responded with
empathy.
For example, women don't know you sex.
No kidding.
I'm not saying they should fall at my feet.
I'm saying I want to improve myself so that
I can have some success with dating.
It was especially frustrating because it was
an emotional support group.
I tried bringing attention to this failure
for a couple of days until the moderators
got involved, accusing me of the very same
things and shaving me.
I gave up.
I left.
I resent them to this day.
And the one thing I wanted to say to them
is something like this is exactly the kind
of response that causes people like me to
get radicalized.
I'm not radicalized, says Rich.
I never will be.
But I am still very much an incel and the
stigma surrounding this is lonely and alienating.
I just straight up don't know what to do about
it.
All I can say is I love to see people like
you covered this with compassion and understanding
and with differentiation between the radicalized
incels and the regular everyday schmucks like
me.
Much love, says rich man.
This is this is a complicated issue.
That is for sure.
And I really, really, really appreciate all
of the feedback about that segment.
We're going to cover it again.
Lastly, Tweeter wrote in and said, if Trump
and his henchmen don't get put away, the world
will think we are weak.
People got hurt and the capital, those charges
should count, too.
This is an argument which is if there are
no consequences to any of the organizers of
the riots, what does it say about the people
thinking about planning something similar?
I think that's a fair question to ask.
Info at David Pakman dot com.
If you have something to say, we have a fantastic
bonus show for you today.
Remember, don't allow yourself to be blocked
from the bonus show.
Get the bonus show by signing up at join Pacman
dot com and remember to subscribe to the YouTube
channel.
There's this sort of bystander effect where
people watch our videos and they go, Oh, he's
got 1.5 million subscribers.
I'm sure other people will subscribe to get
him to 2 million.
No, no, no, no, no.
You can be that person.
Don't fall prey to the bystander effect.
So make sure you're subscribed on YouTube,
YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show, and
we'll be at 2 million.
See you on.
Unidentified: The bonus track.